hey everyone I'm here with Jake at
summer game Fest Jake you gotta play
Remnant two yeah Remnant two it is a
sequel to Remnant From the Ashes which
came out a couple years ago kind of came
out of left field and I think it
impressed a lot of people yeah um I
would say a cult kind of hit yeah it has
a big pretty big fan base yeah and I put
a good amount enjoyed it um but I
haven't really Revisited but I got to
check out Remnant 2 and it seems pretty
promising first of all it is Unreal
Engine 5 and it looks beautiful uh just
exploring that world and seeing how
Fantastical everything is and how
vertical these maps are which is one
thing that when I was talking to the
devs they were saying they really wanted
it to feel more vertical they wanted the
space to feel a little more open a
little more explorable
um when I played it seems that way cool
yeah I mean so like would you say that's
probably like the biggest difference
between this game and the first one
um I I would say well I mean there's
that and there's a bunch of quality of
life updates right we can get into but
um I played in Co-op with with three
people or with two other people
um and I picked a dog class so I had a
pet dog okay that was by my side I could
pet him so yes that's right style dead
to right style exactly yes
um and you could with just Q which just
touch of a button you there's a bunch of
different like context sensitive
commands you could give so if you're
pointing at an enemy and you press it
it'll Rush the enemy if you double tap
it it'll recall the dog closer to you if
you hold it down you'll buff yourself
and your teammates and I think you can
swap the Buffs out with different things
like you can heal you can improve
defense improve Attack Just examples I'm
not sure if that's actually what's in it
but I think mine was improving my
teammates defense which was uh which was
neat um but I think what was really cool
about the dog too is that it kind of
acted as an extra teammate so if an
enemy or if one of my teammates fell
needed to be revived sure I could go
over there and revive him or her but I
could also just send the dog I could
rescue and the dog would run over there
and and it would use one of their revive
hearts and it would it would help him
back up and I was like oh I like this
dog so yeah that was cool but of course
there's other classes um right that you
can try out and uh it's still very like
grounded in that third person like
over-the-shoulder shooter style action
um but it has that Dark Souls Flair to
it kind of I guess it's kind of like the
first one yeah it's a little bit
punishing we fought a boss uh I think I
got downed once
um it was it wasn't too tough but once
again I had a full team games not
entirely balanced uh but yeah like that
aspect was was pretty cool I was having
a good time cool yeah and you said there
was a bunch of quality of life updates
that made kind of this one feel a little
more fresh than the original a number of
quality life updates stuff that I
wouldn't notice if they didn't point out
because like I said it's been a while
since I played the original but just
small things like uh your your inventory
Management's a little easier uh one
thing that they said a lot of players
wanted which I didn't realize you
couldn't do in the original but I guess
when you return to town and you talk to
different
um uh Quest givers and and shops and
stuff like that only one person could
talk to them okay and now multiple
people can go up and talk to them right
right uh there's a there's a shooting
range out there so you can test out your
different weapons that you upgrade and
mod throughout the game uh
but yeah there was like a long list of
uh stuff I don't remember all of them
off the top of my head but um yeah it
seems like they've addressed a lot of
um smaller issues that that cools had
with the original and then the last
thing I kind of want to talk about was
like the visuals because seeing that
initial trailer I was like wow this
looks very impressive and this game's
actually running on on engine five
correct it is an Unreal Engine five game
uh I talked to them a little bit about
it and you know it seems like creating
those bigger more expansive like
vertical worlds are easier to do
um and unreal five
um but also just yeah the visuals look
great just walking around exploring that
area and then watching you know enemies
attack you and how you can roll around
through puddles and and and uh your
character will like automatically jump
up little Ledges and stuff
um so yeah it seems pretty solid it
comes out in I think July 25th so it's
coming pretty soon okay
um I'm definitely I'm definitely gonna
check it out
um like I said I played a good amount of
the first one but didn't really stick to
it but this seems like it's uh solving a
lot of you know smaller pain points that
players had and it it looks like a
a pretty well-rounded sequel awesome
well thank you very much Jake and for
all things summer game Fest stay here at
GameSpot
[Music]